Mexiko ist schon seit einiger Zeit
meinen persönlicher kulinarischer
Sehnsuchtsort seitdem ich einmal richtig
richtig gute Tacos gegessen habe wollte
ich einfach mehr hey Leute Burritos que
serdia alles Sachen die mir Hunger
machen wenn ich sie ausspreche und
dementsprechend muss ich auch in diesem
Format ein Tag essen wie in nach Mexiko
eine Sache die gar nicht so super
einfach ist weil viele der Zutaten hier
schwer zu bekommen oder gar nicht zu
bekommen sind angefangen mit dem
Frühstück zudem ist weathers rancheros
gibt deshalb viel Spaß mit dem Frühstück
und damit kommen wir zum Frühstück wir
haben ja schon die wunderschönsten
Zutaten die man sich nur vorstellen kann
allesamt mexikanisch und wir haben vor
allem hier gewürfelte Zwiebeln die geben
wir in unsere Pfanne die hier gerade
erhitzt mit ein wenig neutralen Öl davon
brauchen wir nicht alles das jetzt eine
ganze nee einfach mal so ein Händchen
vor wenn unsere Zwiebeln schon so ein
bisschen durchsichtig geworden sind aber
immer noch so ein bisschen Biss haben
geben wir vier gewürfelte Tomaten hinzu
sieht es nicht wunderschön aus und dann
haben wir hier eine
Piano Chili die schon fein gehackt habe
Serano Chilis kriegt man hier in
Deutschland relativ schwer die sehen so
aus und es gibt glaube ich im türkischen
Supermarkt auch so eingelegte grüne
Chilis die schmecken ganz ähnlich wenn
ihr es nachmachen wollt nehmt die hat
aber in sich geben wir das nur abgelegt
jetzt
nur den Saft der da drin war aber ich
meine wir sind heute in Mexiko heißt wir
müssen unseren Gaumen ein bisschen
beanspruchen das Kochen wir jetzt so ein
bisschen auf und was wir da machen ist
unsere Salsa ranchera das ist das was
den webOS rein shadows den Namen gibt
also einfach so eine leckere Tomatensoße
mit der wir später die frischen
Tortillas mit knusprigen Spiegeleiern
toppen und es klingt schon wie ein
Gedicht ich habe glatt den Knoblauch
vergessen aber ich finde es eigentlich
gar nicht so schlimm wenn man Knoblauch
nicht so super lange dünstet deshalb
machen wir ihn hier mit ein bisschen Öl
an die Seite ihr merkt schon unsere
salsa ist langsam auch eine Salsa Ali
nimmt schon langsam so eine Form an so
eine Soßen Charakter und Salsa heißt
Soße nee echt der Mexikaner Leute echter
Mexikaner aber Leute Ich sage euch
ehrlich wir haben noch ein bisschen was
eingestellt hier mit den Lampen und so
in der neuen Küche wir haben alle glaube
ich durch krank Hunger und Lust auf das
was uns hier erwartet und ist auch
wirklich ein denkbar einfaches Frühstück
eigentlich weil diese Soße jetzt so
zusammen zu schmeißen weil wirklich
keine große Herausforderung und
ansonsten posten wir Tortillas wir
machen Spiegeleier fertig bauen wir
alles zusammen also wirklich denkbar
einfach aber auch denkbar lecker hier
ist sie unsere Salsa rangera wir füllen
Sie jetzt in eine Schale und dann
schmecke ich sie ein wenig ab mit Salz
und Pfeffer ein zwei Geheimtipps habe
ich auch noch sieht aber auch schon
einfach lecker aus zum Geheimtipp eine
Limette reiben ein wenig zeste ab geben
die noch mit in unsere Salsa ranchera
einfach um so zum zum neuen Geschmack
mit rein zu bekommen wie ich das mal
bitte Erik boah richtig geil die Limette
kommt auch so richtig schön durch hätte
gedacht dass du noch ein bisschen hier
von dahin diesen Ding ist das ja Tim nur
in frisch also Salz Chili Limette aber
dahin kommt am Ende auch noch drüber
trinken
unsere Pfanne wieder heiß so wie wir es
sind auf unsere Körpers rancheros dann
geben wir frischen Kreuzkümmel in unser
Öl gemeinsam mit zwei fein geschnittenen
Knoblauchzehen dass das schöne dass es
ein mexikanisches Produkt ich kann es
hier einfach kaufen das ist eines der
Dinge dass ich liebe daran in der
Großstadt zu leben alles angetoastet
Bohnen drauf
und es geht nur darum sind Temperatur
ranzube kommen wir wollen die nur
erwärmen wir wollen die eigentlich nicht
irgendwie weich kochen oder irgendwas
dann nehmen wir uns und Stampfer und
Stampfen einfach die Hälfte der Boden so
ein bisschen durch paar ganze paar
gestampfte die werden jetzt zu so einer
Paste einkochen und dann können wir hier
auf der anderen Seite unsere planscher
heiß werden lassen dafür braucht ihr
keine planscher das geht auch mit jeder
normalen Pfanne am besten Gusseisen wäre
damit kriegt man so die besten Resultate
das fast wie auf dem Grill hier mit so
einer planschaft wir öffnen unsere
Tortillas auch wieder aus Mexiko Mais
Tortillas riechen wirklich
zu gut die riechen so süßlich ich bin ja
am meisten gespannt auf das Urteil von
Leone leo ist die Benchmark Leo
entscheidet ob wir weiter kochen dürfen
ob wir weiter mexikanisch Kochen dürfen
beim Frühstück heute ihr werdet an der
Videolänge sehen vielleicht schmeckt
jetzt
was ist das Salsa verde die werden wir
später auch noch als Topping verwenden
jeder so wie er Lust hat wir sind jetzt
im Büro das heißt wir essen nicht mehr
alleine sondern jeder kann mal probieren
dann jetzt Eier anbraten anrichten und
essen
[Musik]
sieht das nicht schön aus
gemeinsam mit es hat keinen Namen mit
Bohnen einfach sagen wir jetzt das mit
Bohnen dazu Avocado frischer Koriander
Salsa verde und ich würde sagen wir
machen als allererstes mal den
wichtigsten Test den eigelb-test sah
schon vielversprechend aus aber
sehr sehr gut eigentlich simples
Frühstück aber so viele Geschmacks
geladene Komponenten das ist genau das
weshalb ich dieses Format so gerne mag
dieser Mais mehr Geschmack ne ist
einfach direkt Mexiko für mich
herzhaftes Essen mit Maismehl ich weiß
gar nicht gibt es was gibt es da
großartig nicht so viel ne in Mexiko ist
einfach alles mit meist mir alles mit
Matthias und es schmeckt so lecker
so wichtig dass auch die Tortillas quasi
frittiert werden ne die frische die
sowohl in der Salza Werder aber auch in
der Limette ist die wir hinzugefügt
haben ist ultra geil der Tortilla hat so
ein Crunch aber gleichzeitig so eine
Bissfestigkeit so also außen crunchy
innen drin sowas zum Kauen es hat viel
mehr Substanz als man denkt wenn man so
einen kleinen Fladen da so sieht und
dann denkst du hey Avocado Eigelb cremig
herzhaft gewürzt alles es ist wirklich
ein Gedicht Leo ich reiche dir das
Mikrofon danke was ist das hier los
schmeckst du Mexiko frage ich mich das
ist die große Frage eigentlich doch doch
das machen wir wirklich glücklich ja
geil Alter lass es dir schmecken ich
mach mal weitere Portionen und es
schmeckt die schmeckt gut es wirklich
wirklich sehr lecker geil alter das ist
mein größtes Lob das ist Leo schmeckt
das ist wirklich ein Frühstück was ich
häufiger essen könnte also diese
Vielfalt die verschiedenen Geschmäcker
es war ein bisschen aufwendig natürlich
aber es war schon richtig gut also ich
mag sowieso herzhaftes Frühstück deshalb
Frühstück war für mich persönlich ein
absolute Erfolg haben wir jetzt aber zum
Mittagessen es gibt Tamales etwas was
ich noch nie gegessen habe das macht es
immer ein bisschen schwierig beim Kochen
aber wir haben ja Leo da der seine
fachmännischen Augen auf meinen Versuch
an Tamales legen kann und damit kommen
wir auch zum Mittagessen ich hätte
wirklich keinen blassen Schimmer wenn
ich mir das hier alles anschauen würde
wir haben maishülsen wir haben Fleisch
aus der Schweineschulter wir haben Fett
Maismehl und jede Menge andere Dinge wir
fangen an indem wir hier einen Bräter
auf die Hitze setzen und ordentlich heiß
werden lassen und können zeitgleich
schon mal unsere Schweineschulter packen
und in grobe Würfel schneiden das kann
ich so wahnsinnig leicht zu bekommen
aber bei einem guten Metzger kriegt ihr
auch ein Stück aus der Schweineschulter
dem auch ein ganz traditionelles Gericht
diese Tamales und spätestens wenn ihr
sie gleich sehen werdet wisst ihr warum
so unser neue Herd ist ja bekanntlich
sehr schnell das heißt ich lege hier
schon mal etwas auf und hier ist halt
wichtig deshalb haben wir das auch so
vorbereitet dass der Herd nicht zu voll
wird so das schöne
Röstaromen an unser Fleisch kommt volle
Power und so rösten wir das ganze jetzt
an so die letzte Ladung ist auch
angebraten jetzt geht's ganz einfach
weiter und zwar geben wir unsere
Zwiebeln in den Topf und schaut mal rein
was wir hier alles am Topfboden haben
die Zwiebeln werden jetzt Wasser abgeben
und das alles ablösen und wir verlieren
nichts von dem schönen Geschmack und zu
der fein geschnittenen Zwiebel kommen
vier fein geschnittene Knoblauchzehen
und wenn das ganze ein bisschen
angeschwitzt ist
so wie hier nehmen wir unser
angebratenes Fleisch geben es wieder in
den Topf und was der hier so an
Fleischsaft haben auf dem Tablett gehen
wir auch noch dazu wir wollen nichts
verlieren in diesem schönen Geschmack no
joke Frühstück war schon lecker aber ich
könnte mir vorstellen das wird das
leckerste was wir bisher in dieser Küche
hier gekocht haben 1,3 Liter gefiltert
das Wasser dazu geben wir jetzt noch
frischen Oregano so zwei Äste etwas Salz
frisch gemahlenen schwarzen Pfeffer so
kochen wir das ganze jetzt auf und dann
stellen wir das ganze auf unsere
zweitkochplatte und lassen es für zwei
Stunden köcheln dann können wir
weitermachen mit dem restlichen
Vorbereitung anderthalb Stunden sind
vergangen und das Innere ist bestimmt
auch heiß es sieht sehr gut aus es
riecht vor allem sehr gut aber bin
gespannt wie die Konsistenz von unserem
Fleisch jetzt ist weil davon hängt quasi
der ganze Erfolg ab wir brauchen eine
kleine Schüssel und jetzt holen wir
unser Fleisch und nur unser Fleisch raus
geben das in die Schüssel das lassen wir
ein bisschen abkühlen bevor wir es
gleich auseinander massieren können dann
machen wir weiter mit unseren maishülsen
die sehen so aus auch glaube ich relativ
schwer zu bekommen in Deutschland die
müssen wir jetzt erstmal für eine halbe
Stunde in Wasser einlegen bzw habe ich
schon gemacht ich muss ein bisschen
vorsichtig sein dass ich nicht alles
unter Wasser setze so sieht das Ganze
aus wenn die sich mit Wasser vollgesogen
haben dann machen wir weiter mit unseren
Chilis wir haben ja einmal gojillo und
einmal ancho die werden wir erstmal
entkernen könnt ihr ja von den Beria
Tacos machen wir die einmal auf das sind
auch die gleichen Chilis tatsächlich
oder ja genau Gorilla und Anton für den
Tipico Mexican flavour Alter irgendwie
schon so jetzt nehmen wir unsere Chilis
geben die in eine Form drückt ihr so ein
bisschen zusammen und jetzt möchten wir
ihnen ihre Feuchtigkeit wieder
hinzufügen in Form von unserer Brühe
besser geht's nicht besser geht's nicht
ich bin mir sicher die wird jetzt auch
nicht ihre Farbe behalten Zeit ist
glaube ich in der mexikanischen Küche
eine Schlüsselkomponente aber eigentlich
in fast jeder guten Küche wir machen
jetzt den Test mit unserem Fleisch und
es zerfällt wie von selbst in der Hand
mit ein bisschen Druck haben wir hier
wirklich schönes faseriges Fleisch als
nächstes brauchen wir den Kollegen hier
wir kümmern uns nämlich jetzt um unsere
eingelegten Chilis zack ein bisschen von
unserer Brühe geben wir dazu den Rest
bewahren wir natürlich trotzdem auf so
was würden wir niemals wegwerfen
sieht aber sehr gut aus wie wie stark
das steht zumäßig super fein ja genau
damit gehen wir direkt rüber zu unserem
Fleisch nehmen etwa die Hälfte von
unserer Soße
junge junge Junge kann sich sehen lassen
rühren die einen marinieren unser
Fleisch wie auch immer man will jetzt
ist er erst so der Geschmack dran
gekommen wir greifen uns eine große
Schüssel geben da rein Schweineschmalz
250 g und rühren den jetzt schaumig bin
selbst gespannt ob das funktioniert wie
das funktioniert es ist zumindest das
was wir tun sollen ein Mann mit einer
Mission ich habe es jetzt nicht ganz
flüssig bekommen eher so ein bisschen
cremig das wird aber auch gar nicht
weiter schlimm sein wir geben nämlich im
nächsten Schritt unser Mehl dazu und
dann fügen wir so lange Brühe hinzu bis
wir die gewünschte Konsistenz haben das
heißt die Konsistenz erreichen wir hoffe
ich mal als allererstes einmal das Mehl
dazu das ist lustig nee einfach Maismehl
und das ist so blau ja ich check das
auch nicht es gibt ja so viele
verschiedene Sorten meist auch so viele
verschiedene maismähle es muss am Ende
fast so ein bisschen cremig sein von der
Konsistenz her wie so ein Brei da
brauchen wir noch mehr Flüssigkeit das
fügen wir jetzt immer weiter hinzu bis
wir die gewünschte Konsistenz erreicht
haben und dann verspreche ich Euch es
war ein langer Weg ist es auch soweit
das Warten hat ein Ende wir nehmen uns
jetzt eine gut durchsaugte maishülse
legen Sie hier einfach mal auf die
Arbeitsfläche dann brauchen wir ein
wenig von unserem Gemisch aus Schmalz
und Maismehl nehmen wir ein bisschen
Frischhaltefolie drücken das ganze platt
in der Mitte dann nehmen wir unser
mariniertes Fleisch
packen das in die Mitte ein Drittel
davon muss ungefähr bedeckt sein wir
rollen das Ganze einmal rüber schließen
ist öffnen es noch mal kurz und dann
verschließen wir ganz
Rollen zusammen das aber schon öfter
gemacht oder Falten von unten hoch und
dann habe ich mir hier so aus den
trockenen kornhülsen einen kleinen Faden
gemacht und mit diesem Faden bin ich
jetzt meine Tamaris zusammen
sieht aber schon echt ansehnlich aus das
mache ich jetzt ein paar mal und dann
dünsten wir die Dinger
[Musik]
wundert euch auch bitte nicht über diese
Konstruktion wir haben einen Topf
mitgebracht der nicht induktionsgeeignet
ist und wir dämpfen jetzt unsere
thermale setzt hier ein Einsatz mal
hinein damit wir die Dinger hier stellen
können oder dass sie hoffentlich alle
schön stehen bleiben Höhe ist auch
perfekt wir haben neue Sorge ist perfekt
das ist nicht passen würde und so
dünsten wir die jetzt für eine halbe 3/4
Stunde Deckel drauf warten und dann
endlich essen eine Brandblase später
gucken wir uns das mal an
ihr merkt das Leo hinter der Kamera der
konnte sich einfach nicht mehr entgehen
lassen langer Weg zu unserem heutigen
Mittagessen dampfende Tamaris und ich
finde wenn man das so schon vor sich
stehen hat dann hat man das Gefühl man
hat irgendwas gemacht was zumindest ein
bisschen authentisch ist aber es klebt
ein wenig es sieht okay aus ich finde es
sieht sehr gut aus ja es ist super weich
geworden es ist ein bisschen anders als
das glaube ich sein müsste wir gehen mal
ein bisschen was von unserer Chilisauce
rüber dann nehme ich sehr gespannt ne
hoffentlich schmeckt wenigstens
eigentlich die richtigen Zutaten
[Musik]
kannst du es überhaupt beurteilen ob es
richtig schmeckt oder nicht beurteilen
ob es richtig schmeckt die wollen ganz
anders das Ding du musst es gleich
probieren ja ich kann aber beurteilen
dass es mir zumindest schmeckt okay es
ist ein bisschen komisch weil es wieso
Brei ist fast ein bisschen das Mehl
so wie ist die Konsistenz ist
wahrscheinlich oft ne also es muss nicht
so breit sein aber es schmeckt der
Geschmack ist gut ne der Geschmack ist
on point und die konnte so dieses
klebrige mehlige ist auch typisch
eigentlich ja finde es aber ernst lecker
ich finde so richtig lecker die sind
Soße ist so crazy bekannt dass harte
Fleisch ist halt eh krass schmecken sie
dir so gut dass du noch einen essen
möchtest safe dann würde ich sagen gebe
ich Leo jetzt mal einen Tamale ich war
mal eine kleine Verschnaufpause von
unserem Mittagessen das war wirklich
sehr fordernd jetzt aber heute Abend
muss ich nicht in der Küche stehen
darüber bin ich sehr froh denn wir gehen
Tacos Essen daran merkt man das wirklich
nicht alles immer klappt und auch mit
einem guten Rezept und viel Vorbereitung
geht mal was schief deshalb würde ich
sagen lass uns doch fürs Abendessen die
Profis ran lassen wir gehen in einen
brandneu eröffnetes mexikanisches
Restaurant was an diesem Tag aufgemacht
hat und wir essen uns durch die gesamte
Speisekarte klingt gut ich würde sagen
ja wir bestellen Tacos Lotte und alles
was das Herz begehrt ab an den
Rheinauhafen
in Köln das ist Abendstimmung aber
hinter uns ist mexikanische Wärme in
einem wirklich wunderschönen Laden ich
habe gerade mal durch die Scheibe
reingeschaut der Grille ist heiß das
Essen ist heiß und da drin bebt die
Hütte möchte man fast sagen also es ist
richtig was los hoffentlich ist das
Essen auch genauso gut aber was ich da
so gesehen habe auf dem Grill
verschiedene kleine Tacos ein Pastor
Spieß der sich dreht und ich habe das
Gefühl dass wir hier wirklich einen
authentischen mexikanischen Laden
gefunden hat der noch mehr als Tacos zu
bieten hat glaube es ist falsch hier
noch weiter draußen zu stehen und drüber
zu reden wir sollten reingehen wir
sollten zu uns schmecken lassen und wir
sollten einen schönen Abend haben nicht
nur zu zweit sondern wir sind in großer
Runde unter anderem Margarita ist dabei
die Margarita die kolumbianische Mama es
gibt leckere Tacos und es gibt keinen
Grund länger hier draußen zu stehen
deshalb ab rein mit uns und eine schöne
Abend haben ich glaube viel muss ich
nicht sagen ihr seht das was ich hier
offen war wir haben eine unglaubliche
Vielfalt von Tacos wir haben eine Lotte
ein unintelligible mit Käse mit Tahin
wir haben eine quesadilla wir haben
originale mexikanische Soßen und wir
haben einen sehr sehr hungrigen Lachs
der jetzt einfach anfängt zu essen ist
mir komplett egal was Erik jetzt sagt
ich nehme diesen Takko ich nehme mir ein
bisschen von dieser Formatierung Soße
boah krass das hier sind wahrscheinlich
canitas
schön mit Mango Salsa
oder ich sage dir ehrlich
am Tag wo wir hier sind hat dieser Laden
aufgemacht und ich habe immer gedacht
wenn wir machen einen Tag essen wie in
Mexiko können wir nicht essen gehen weil
wir werden kein authentisch
mexikanisches Essen finden und es ist zu
uns gekommen das ist eine Fügung dass
der Laden heute aufgemacht hat es
schmeckt einfach krank es schmeckt
wirklich sehr sehr krank kleine
Feinheiten die du eigentlich nicht
erwartest in Deutschland
okay
der musste nicht sein er hat mit meinen
Gefühlen gespielt
[Musik]
Margarita auch als Kolumbianerin muss
man mexikanisches Essen bewerten ich
glaube das Urteil zählt viel mehr als
abends aber es ist wirklich köstlich
also reden der Zunge man denkt
vielleicht nicht aber das ist krass
was für eine Stimmung was für ein Tag
also die mexikanische Küche hat mich
genauso fest im Griff wie vor diesem
Video wenn ich noch mehr es war alles
unfassbar lecker ich habe echt Lust auch
weitere südamerikanische Länder
kulinarisch zu bereisen aber schreibt
ihr doch mal eure landesempfehlung in
die Kommentare wo soll ich als nächstes
hin was euch als nächstes ausprobieren
ich bin sehr gespannt auf eure
Vorschläge wenn euch das Video gefallen
hat lasst gerne ein Like da klickt auf
das hier für euch vorgeschlagene
persönliche Video und aktiviert die
Glocke das wäre extrem nett denn es
hilft mir meine Miete zu bezahlen
tschüss bis zum nächsten Mal